Identification this is an interview with the Faith Bandler and pain
and pray session one eight one five one accorded in Sydney on Anzac Day April twenty five nineteen ninety seven,
the tape begins in approximately ten seconds time they say.
Let's begin at the beginning where were you born at school in the village on the north coast of New South Wales.
The name of the village 's well it only had to.
It had to pass our data adequate to grocery stores, Baker and a butcher who was North consultant will
and they were linked by a ferry service which elected continues a shout all about ferry service was very important,
but so was that the ferry man as we called in to your and ran the fairy he lived close day
and we liked him because we buffered with him a little she had decent we had chooks use in the resort was a bit of an
exchange. but If I make to the hole that I was born in adequate period editor.
It was made of lamps of feed timber theatre was grounded in that area that the area had grapeseed forests before they
were all chopped up and sent off
and it is that house very fresh in my memory to the kitchen that had now if you will start
and a great big table in the centre out that Armidale, then it had two bedrooms of the and one-bedroom for the law.
He later said that he and my mother and father 's bedroom and it was all very rough, some L3.
Our floor was actually made us see that as land and in the winter.
My mother will down make sure that there were many to keep the place.
All rights for the floor
and somebody's she would make itself from the scraps that were left over from our address issues make a student
and align it with a line that would cash in the house. All this of course was third dealt by my father.
The powers are all part of his that countrymen
and they were made up basically a twenty people who escaped are working from on the canefields in North Queensland,
and they had come down to the Tweed in that area to be independent to start their market gardens and so forth.
So they help my father back up the timber they wanted to the forest timber
and they built this was a very open as it had done this sick Bay and I am how and
when these people who come from the at the word were dysplasia. Since little trains are came out of the Tweed.
It was cold and many of them go to bronchitis and banking influenza bronchitis, pneumonia
and that they would come to our play
and they will someone a rare in fact that they be allowed today is the last time at night would be taken care of by a
mother mother and will keep on going to wait on the mother mother would say, for instance, cooking the evening meal
and then she set up a great big tin tray which were used to trace
and that she get us to take the merely hinder whoever was sick and is a very sick. She certainly tender my illness.
Remember, so that people who had a temperature and should take the addition of cold water and a small bowel
and Kalimna bring the clutter and put it on the forehead the fan and coolant.
Sometimes my father would call the ambulance.
Then they go off to hospital
but many a time they would just stay there someone he'll make that my mother 's attention and good care
and they go path that many eight two, so the existence and efficient manner
and to search our early childhood memories now that was my mother 's kitchen that had described with the table in the
centre
and so forth at the best thing at the back of the hut that was whether vegetable out what this which will eventually
lived after that we never knew that there was such a thing as the greengrocer in existence at whilst my father 's
outhouse kitchen is to have it was just made a ten under high and it had an earthen floor and matter
and flooring in the centre was this huge log fireplace
and at night after the evening the little woodchips would Gandhi who is our father
and we had done to my thesis to sit on,
which will really the case that was used for packing bananas in an my father had he is that no one would ever sit on
his hands at the bus would just take over) sit on the floor is very close to the phone at the farm was wonderful
and there was a huge kettle hung on the English chain from the year roof and it would be
and it good being softly as background music to this storytelling engine
and the way a certain story which happen to be is not my favourite may be the favourite of one of my sisters all one
hundred and to mislead or gather around the fire we all put in for our favourite story and I can before
and as he told of whilst he told a thousand times and afterwards Bayesian again and again and again
and I didn't understand.
but That was about until Bethlehem granddaughter and she would want to hear the same story thousand pounds
and he would tell us the and the story and it was when he will want to illustrate, for instance, how far
when he was kidnapped and taken by the latest and what it was like in the coming over from his island
and broken in the new pretext.
The class and how they will feel the whole
and how to think that with those who doubt they would be thrown overboard Howard,
whilst the money that was a variety of Australia and Australians.
Everything seemed to him and I just ask you what year it was that he was taken from the meeting
and also how old was he and what were his reaction as that presumably very young man, so he was about thirteen,
in the year of eighteen eighty three when he was captured and brought to Australia landed in my car.
They
and herself always remember him telling us that stranger files to see these huge animals like the great draft told that
a that and all the beautiful bird that was strange to hear Matt and powers it in her it was Sam
and another world another world, so these stories would go around the fireplace and as intelligent,
once we beg for him to tell it again and again and he liked Festival Hall wants wits with powers to the car
and he say all that he is now it is all current cars car being forced fantastic he that they became
and its baby car came the mother cow. He was a boy of thirteen or fourteen. Such a large animals.
He had never seen through the stories would go around fireplace.
The dreams he would have known he was great believer in tree
and likely to keep retailers stories around the fireplace at night and they next morning, very early, of course,
as we have relevant as she would try and recaptured history
and then he interpreted according to what he believed all conditions like when he first came to Australia what,
what work was to do and where what he was them that will hinder thirteen fourteen when he arrived in Australia
and conditions.
Even in the staff were very primitive follow from all workers
but it's hard to describe how hard it flies in North Queensland.
It was the least circulating at the same
when the cane industry started in the north that it was too hot for paying workers to work in that industry the now
that was the excuse used by the traders in Islanders Lara is that they need black people who could stand up to fifty
and the Queensland Gap State government in fact accepted that without question
and do so that Turkey was one of sixty thousand who was brought over from the islands were kidnapped.
Most of its true, some say that they agreed to cut agreed to come.
I don't dispute back, but only gather stories of my father told me so as the younger, i.e.
He was in those days they were being so on.
I'll I think it was seventy pounds ahead the bigger they were all they got the men from China at AMP,
which was my phone as they will quite be quite tall.
He was very to all heedless that it are six one three six foot for any humans bit free say he was sent to work on the
farm billeted in that which was built in for those who are brought over to where they had men's barracks
and women's barracks in the city of Mackay in north Queensland
and the sun will actually be sent at the barracks because they were very hot in summer
and they took to building their own
and shacks with thatched roofs cc with cooler for the summer months while he was found he was related.
All he was put to live with all the men and he fathers of his age.
when The sun was at a summarised in the morning the Belmont during the whistle
and they have to be ready to go into the field and they would work there until sunset, then that their number.
Chris and they would be allowed to go back to the barracks and they had a ration and it was a very poor race and many,
many of those people that are in fact they would be dropping dead in the canefields and buried, Graves,
mainly because of the strange life regular hours hard work can be for 's hand
and no longer having than nourishing diet of all fish and seafood are good however the lens you sweet potatoes,
tomatoes, wasn't there and they were given rations but the owners of the same,
that the aboriginal people were given on their research that was flour tea, sugar much else.
In fact, and fall from the slaughter houses if they were lucky,
so it is in fact seventy died that a Royal commission was established in Queensland to investigate the living
conditions of the island was at the data. The findings were that they were seen to be very undernourished.
My father stayed there and worked on the plane and for about twenty years
and finally he felt well enough is in his brother was brought with him and who was my uncle
and said well you can hang research and kind.
It is my twenty year will Henry 's yarn,
and he was/ Annandale is in what happened was that there were like my aunt Kate also came
and that she was working in the house of the owner of the came and she became she was became a very able capable
and manager out household duties, and when it became was put in charge of the Adelaide servants
and their job of course was basically Audrey to the cooking
and I think that some of these people survived because of what Kate was getting regularly and at worst,
taking the home-made matter and nourishment from the farmers kitchen and she taken at night to the barracks.
It is a bit of nourishment is easier to boil the water before they drank at the simple things like that.
and Of course the English game for an Irishman boss at which was very valuable because it was turned into sugar,
so I am not just my father 's life that they had twenty year are they were called the Queensland government call them
connected and that is the other way and word which he just man,
and yet they were people who came from many different gardens with their very different cultures
and do you like saying out to a hunger calling a hung area.
The French person or a French person that German or whatever sales letter
and they had been you continue with their different cultures and health
but they were all just bundled in the melting pot as they can adjust men.
They are throughout the strong objection taken to the word, and although it is still used today,
particularly by historians anthropologist 's bad turn my father objected to it very strongly.
Yesterday I come from aim is my highlight it is not to am a it's not down any injury at Pentecost in India,
and were different,
so of course in many ways they were forced to lose their identity are so he ended his brother having
and their sister Kate spent twenty years working after some years they were paid that paid very, very little.
It's true they had their own way of an entertaining themselves are negative work on a Sunday
and the farmers always organised as a Christian to give them some lessons in Christ
and it is all a bit of a mystery to my father because he says it
and believe it if I can't walk on water lather cameraman Jesus Walker brought the more you just being very practical
anyhow, they were always expected to lead to church
and they went to church because that provided them with a very good opportunity of coming together in seeing each other
but couldn't it during the week to target exhausted they have to sleep some days they go to church because that's what
it was a mapping together are some of them were able to play the piano accordion they look great at that
and the little small following a ball and paint play by year, mainly in the city absolutely loved it.
That was carried on ropes enough.
I was a sad debating just in the church
or to the season at other times as well well… usually put that the service was often held under a big mango tree
and they have made in the church, but they are before or after you now this is a feast day or so
and have been cooked left much more toe for something a little special tell me the story of how your father left these
conditions.
He was twenty years in Mackay probity get out when it had a gut full of all of this after a while,
and there he wanted her money, you really be able to buy beds, chairs and whatever,
like the extent that they are not quite sure whether her his brother, my uncle Charles
and auntie Kate gathered up the goods and shackles
and went together with him whether I think he went to learn the estimate went a little later
and don't so he learned he ran away year one and he only travel during the night
and during the dateline in the bushes doesn't sleep mailing staff
and he did that from a kite in Brisbane because he didn't want to be seen yesterday at the he the many beautiful stream
was by the roadside.
The unmade roads streams from the mountains you could thought it was clear crystal just beautiful
and down at he had fought and varies of all kinds probably not dead brown bandicoot or Paddy Mallon, or something
and he did take on matters and things with him so he was able to feed himself on the way down
and data guess he read it affirmative bananas or whatever was going and eventually here who arrived in Brisbane.
Well,
he'd always heard about Brisbane while he was still in McCartney discrete city in the staff while he was still in the
car he had observed of my auntie Kate is to do the house should be to add a few clues about running a house that
when he got to Brisbane to hear.
He went and got a job in a house for a woman who left all alone
and she paid him she had to listen very welcome common
and festival she employed him as the gardener in the suburb of what it is wanted was the Albion then which adjoins
Clayfield.
This is very harsh in the anyhow, he started off with the garden
and then he said she got him to do the floors of the house
and he really enjoyed that isn't carried wrap the line on delinquencies faith in our
and then the she started to show palatable in an EA and if you think the fat
and in any he was doing everything for her everything all cooking gardens shopping the extruding about it.
He told us that she only had one drink
and it was his job to wash that drink every evening after he served firmly in cheek
and get into had nothing down the dressing gown and he'd take that dread and is doing very,
very hard that would dry overnight and he would find it in the morning it given to her in.
She put it on wealthier will I shall effect/ eighty there and then receive the promises I want system hard with you
and really work there. He left Brisbane and then hit it off to walk to cross the Queensland border.
That's a hundred miles was at fifty.
Anyhow it was peanuts to him absolutely nothing great tall stroll of thirty -year-old that took at any strike he
arrived at journos versus Canada is an very found quite a few morale and and do so they all together very quickly.
He meant the whose parents were from Sweden and she was a place with the island as she do things on washing, cooking
or whatever. This was that surfers Paradise. She was a very tightly little person.
She wasn't a warm and she was only ago and she didn't seem to belong to anyone.
No parent is no family learnt nothing so now my father felt very sorry for her
but he said he couldn't stay there he wanted to go to a place where he could get a farm of his own,
so he walked away from surfers Paradise went down across the border is killing at walked through twenty ten out through
single to college on what is known as Kings case today,
and there was already established quite a number of violent events share marketing share farming with bananas with
white farmers receipts and very, very quickly. He got pensions settled in Lauer.
I want activists woman to whom he may in certain spirit after a short while this woman appear and could you
when she was.
She then brought by some other Ireland women who were moving over to we could,
you could was now had a reputation among the islanders that was a good place to settle and it was nice
and the farmers were good and they paid a decent wage so the woman came in couldn't she had nothing
and someone saw her she was only about fourteen or fifteen feet and some sort, and they took to the police station
and one of my father 's country went into the police station for something or another, and the police daily.
This manager is to know anybody get out of her into pieces of what we don't what to do with her.
They, and he took the young woman
and by then the island people had built their own church with her own hands that could you
and him who this woman in the church and they had fourteen children.
Now that family became very important family to my family
and its name is icon IT LNG that men came from the island of Tanner which is one immediately in what was the new
favourite is done about the delay in.
He married this will and had all his children but then mine turned up in collection and am not quite sure how and by
but she turned up.
Mum had been married and her first husband had done and she arrived with two little girls
and she had nothing with actually nothing that she had a lot of now out how to make layers harder call Y Shadow line
how to do all those things perfectly so in a very short time she got a job without any trouble in keeping task
and that was where she met my father was the background while you know my mother was stuck up, you will believe it.
Polly stricken
and stuck mother once the child of a Scottish woman who had come out to Australia with her employers as the main
seamstress for the lady and a loss that Scottish culture had rubbed off on